MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, Special Relativity.
In this section we're
going to talk a bit more
about collisions.
I've already seen collisions in
study of momentum conservation
in previous sections.
So here we can have a collision.
Then we can describe them
in the center of mass frame,
for example, where the total
momentum is equal to 0.
So in the case of the
collision of two particles,
the momentum of particle
one plus the momentum
of particle two is equal to 0.
We can then describe the
energy and the momentum
of the particles before
and after the collision.
In the lab frame, the
situation is different.
Here typically we
have one particle
with some momentum hitting
another particle, which
is at rest.
But we can also have
different types of collisions.
We describe or characterize
elastic collisions
where the kinetic energy is
conserved and so is the mass.
So you can think about two
billiard balls colliding
without any friction,
in which case
they don't change their
appearance, their mass.
Everything is unchanged, so
you must change the direction.
The total kinetic energy
in these collisions
are typically conserved.
But we can also have
inelastic collisions.
And there's two different kinds.
There's sticky kinds, where
the mass after the collision
is greater.
So you have two
particles, for example,
maybe they stick together--
they're some, like,
Play Dough balls--
and the kinetic energy after
the collision is smaller.
Or you can have explosive
collisions, where
the mass afterwards is smaller.
Maybe you start from
one heavy, big object
and then which explodes
into many smaller ones.
But the kinetic energy after
the collisions is much smaller.
Those are also collisions.
So here we want
to do an activity
and study an
inelastic collision.
So before we have two particles
there, or billiard balls.
They're exactly the same
and have a velocity u.
And after the collision their
mass is capital M, big mass.
And you're going to
describe this collision once
in the center of mass frame and
one in the laboratory frame.
And so the question
now is, are the masses
and is energy conserved
in those collisions?
And you're going
to just described
this in both reference forms.
So again, stop the video here
and try to work this out.
I already did this,
so I discussed
before, in those
collision problems
it's always important
to be really clear.
The situation
before the collision
was A. The situation
after the collision was B.
So I'm describing this here.
First in the center of
mass frame where the x--
and I'm just talking
about x component here--
the x momentum is 0, which
is equal to the mass times u
times gamma minus the
mass times u terms gamma.
That's the 0.
The energy before is 2 times
the mass times gamma times
c squared.
After the collision,
the particle is at rest.
The new one
particular is at rest
and has an energy,
large M over--
times c squared.
In the laboratory frame
situations, different case.
X momentum 0 minus
m times u prime--
this is a different velocity--
times gamma of u prime.
So here I'm trying to indicate
that this gamma is not
the same gamma as over here.
This is a gamma, but it's
the velocity of u prime.
And the energy is the rest
mass of the particle addressed
plus the mass times
gamma times c squared off
the second particle.
After the collision, the
particle has some velocity u.
And so the momentum
in x direction
is minus large M times u
times gamma of u again.
And the energy is large M
times gamma u times c squared.
OK, good.
So now we can use
momentum conservation
and find this equation here.
And from which we
can then calculate
that the large mass is equal
to 2 times the smaller mass.
So what you find, and this
is the relativistic math,
you find that at the conclusion
that the rest mass is not
conserved.
The mass of this big
ball is not simply
the mass of the two
rest masses, or 2 times
the mass of the rest mass.
You have to consider
this gamma factor here.
It's 2 times the relativistic
math, if you want.
But you also find
that the total energy
is conserved in circulation so
that the sum of m0 gamma times
c squared is conserved
in the collision,
irrespectively in how
you actually reference it
when you discuss the problem.
I want to close this
part of collisions
with a small
discussion of units.
And that will become
interesting and important later
on when we look at
particle physics examples.
So in particle
physics, we often talk
about units of electronvolt
in collision experiments,
or mega electronvolts,
or kilo electronvolts,
tera electronvolts.
So 1 electronvolt is
the kinetic energy
of the particle with charge
e, which is accelerated
in a potential of 1 volts.
So that corresponds--
that's a unit of energy
and it corresponds
to 1.6 times 10
to the minus 19
joules or 1.6 times 10
to the minus 90 kilograms
meter squared over 2nd square.
But the mass of an electron
is really, really small.
And those units
here are introduced
because the mass
is small and you
want to have reasonable
numbers to work with.
So the mass of the
electron is 9.11 times
10 to the minus 31 kilogram.
So if you just rewrite an m0 as
equal to m0 c squared times 1
over c squared you
find that, huh,
now we rewrite this and find
that the masses 8 times 10
to the minus 14
joules over c squared.
Or in units of
electronvolts, 5 times 10
to the 5 electronvolts
over c squared,
which is 0.511 mega
electronvolts over c squared
or 511 kilo electrons
over c squared.
So when we talk about
the mass of an electron,
we sometimes approach this
with natural units, in which c
squared is equal to 1.
And that just simply says
that the mass of an electron
is 511 kilo electronvolts.
The math of a neuron
is mega electronvolts,
and so on, and so on.